[Music]
there are many clever Illusions and
references in Netflix's new mystery
movie Enola Holmes and some of them can
be a little hard to spot but we're here
to clue you in here are some of the more
amusing little morsels to uncover in
Enola
homes Enola Holmes takes place in the
same Victorian era London setting as the
classic Sherlock Holmes stories while
maintaining a distinctively modern feel
the movie operates from a feminist and
female Centric perspective told from the
point of view of Sherlock's younger
sister s Enola it's so focused on
women's issues social Liberation and a
feminine perspective that it ends up
being extremely reminiscent of the
well-regarded modern series flea bag
Phoebe Waller Bridges Emmy winning hit
about the messy life of a young English
woman dealing with grief self-loathing
and family conflict just like in the one
woman show that inspired the series the
title character of flea bag constantly
breaks the fourth wall to deliver
Exposition reflect on plot developments
and make fun of other characters in the
story Enola Holmes features its Title
Character doing all those things as well
keeping the audience well informed of
her thoughts throughout the film I knew
that was a flaw let me
think do you have any ideas the flea bag
connections to Enola Holmes Run deeper
than a casual disregard for the fourth
wall both Productions co-starred Fiona
Shaw and Enola Holmes was directed by
Harry bradbeer who also helmed 11
episodes of flea bag Enola Holmes
reimagines the mystery solving world of
Sherlock Holmes Through The Eyes of his
teenage sister Enola the film explains
that Enola is much younger than her
brothers Sherlock and microft raised on
the Family's remote country estate by
their widowed mother it's a clever bit
of casting to place Millie Bobby Brown
in the role the actor is best known for
her role as telekinetic test subject 11
on Netflix's stranger things after
escaping from a secret government
institution she falls under the care of
small town sheriff Jim Hopper
he becomes her deao father and in the
second season the two of them live
together in Hopper's remote Cabin in the
Woods outside of Hawkins Indiana in
other words she's got more in common
with anola than you might first believe
for brown portraying a kid bristling
against parental control while keeping
herself occupied at home out in the
country turned out to be a great way to
prepare for Enola homes anagrams are an
important plot device in Enola Holmes
the titular teen detective States early
on that her name is the word alone
spelled back words later when her mother
disappears and uses ciphers as Clues to
her whereabouts Enola uses Scrabble like
letter tiles to unscramble the letters
and clarify the message an anagram is
also the method by which Harry Potter
author JK Rowling reveals the origin of
the series villain Voldemort Harry
Potter in the Chamber of Secrets
explains that the letters in the name of
former Hogwart student Tom marvelo
Riddle rearrange to spell out I Am Lord
Voldemort riddle grows up to lead a dark
Army of wizards among them Bellatrix L
strange portrayed in the Harry Potter
movies by Helena bonam Carter who plays
udor Holmes in Netflix's mystery the
film was also written by Jack Thorne
co-author of the play Harry Potter and
the cursed child the central mystery of
Inola Holmes concerns the sudden
disappearance of udor the mother of
Sherlock microft and Enola ud's
mysterious departure occurs on the
morning of enola's 16th birthday
prompting Sherlock and mic to return to
the family's country home moft is more
annoyed than worried and comments upon
his confusion over the situation perhaps
she was mad or
scile there Madness in our family I
would doubt it this whole situation
connects Enola Holmes to another
modern-day reinterpretation of the
Sherlock Holmes Universe on the BBC
series Sherlock it's revealed that the
detective has a sister he doesn't
remember named Urus she is evil
imprisoned and tries Tri to kill
Sherlock's assistant John Watson much
like Enola Sherlock's institutionalized
sister was also subjected to a lot of
aone time but in her case the isolation
was a little bit more Justified when
Enola Holmes Ventures into London to try
to solve the mystery of her mother's
disappearance she winds up entangled in
another pressing conundrum why VI count
tberry the Marquess of Basil weather is
on the run from his family pursued by a
violent man who keeps trying to kill him
presenting herself as a 22-year-old
woman named May beatric posie she gains
access to Basil weather by pretending to
be the assistant of Sherlock Holmes her
scheme is nearly foiled upon the arrival
of Inspector lrad the Scotland Yard
detective who is Sherlock Holmes contact
in the English police system he calls
out the so-called Miss posie on her
claim of being holm's assistant stating
matter of factly that the detective
doesn't have one he doesn't have an
assistant Sherlock Holmes always works
alone
but Sherlock Holmes famously does have a
helper not may beatric posie but Dr John
Watson this means that in the Sherlock
Holmes chronology Inola Holmes takes
place after Sherlock Holmes becomes
famous but before he meets his assistant
best friend and partner in crime solving
anola Holmes is the latest high-profile
take on the literary Creations that Sir
Arthur Conan doy brought to life in the
late
1800s even though Enola herself was
created by author Nancy Springer in 2006
the movie pays homage to its
predecessors when Enola runs off to
follow a lead on a case a pivotal moment
in the film she declares the game is a
foot this is a phrase coined by William
Shakespeare but it became closely
associated with enola's brother Sherlock
one of the most famous and prolific
onscreen portrayers of Sherlock Holmes
is actor basil Rathbone who played the
detective in 15 movies in the 1930s and
1940s the folks behind Enola Holmes
threw out a nod to the star using his
first name as part of a character's
Family Estate a detail you may pick up
on is denola helps out the distressed
Marquess of Basil weather dates flash on
screen quickly in anola home so it's
easy to miss exactly when the film story
line takes place audiences with at least
a passing familiarity with the Sherlock
Holmes stories can tell that the movie
like most other fiction about the
character takes place in London during
the reign of Queen Victoria in the
Industrial Age sometime before the of
the 20th century a couple of small Clues
from the political climate that forms a
backdrop of the plot of Inola Holmes
indicates to the audience that the film
takes place specifically in
1884 Enola pursues two cases over the
course of the film The Disappearance of
her mother and the motivation for the
attacks on the marquest of Basil weather
although they began as seemingly
unrelated Mysteries the two cases
ultimately dovetail by the story's End
enola's mother udor takes off off for
London to influence Parliament through
extreme tactics to enact Progressive new
policies aimed at ultimately extending
voting rights to women the marquest
meanwhile inherited a seat in
parliament's House of Lords from his
deceased father parties opposed to a
progressive new law to significantly
expand the voting electorate aim to make
sure he doesn't vote in favor of it by
killing him before he has the chance not
many details of this law are provided
but Enola Holmes is referring to the
representation of the people act of 1884
also called the 1884 Reform Act which
expanded voting rights throughout the
United Kingdom the plot of Enola Holmes
grows more complicated when Enola gets
sidetracked from her mission to find her
mother by the situation involving VI
count tberry marquest of Basil weather
after Enola discovers him hidden in a
piece of luggage in her train
compartment they jump off the moving
locomotive together to escape a Hitman
trying to kill the young nobleman Enola
vows to help determine why exactly her
new friend has a bounty on his head
momentarily pausing her quest to locate
her mother it's a little curious why
Enola Holmes would take this path and
something as simple as a crush on the
marquest feels far too basic for such a
self-assured independent character the
real reason Enola Holmes helps the
marquest is because she sees a lot of
herself in him by helping him with his
predicament she's also bettering her
understanding of who she is after poking
around his family's estate she finds the
marquis's Treehouse ref refuge and it's
clear his happiest moments as a child
were spent in the countryside bopping
around the woods outside the
well-appointed home of a rich prominent
family Inola experienced a similar
upbringing she was a wild child raised
in a country home of the rich prominent
homes family Arthur Conan Doyle debuted
the character of Sherlock Holmes with
the story a study in Scarlet in
1887 just over 50 years later another
enduring Larger than Life character made
his first appearance in an issue of
Action Comics Superman an alien who
comes to Earth and becomes a superhero
over the decades both Sherlock and
Superman have been the central
characters of numerous books television
shows and movies most recently Superman
has figured prominently in movies like
justice league in Batman versus Superman
dawn of Justice both of which saw him
portrayed by Henry caval caval takes on
a supporting role in Enola Holmes as the
supportive Sherlock but when his
character is introduced early in the
film it's done so via a splashy Montage
lock ing him as a famous detective as
well as a scholar chemist voso violinist
expert Marksman swordsman single stick
fighter pugilist and Brilliant deductive
thinker it's a resume that Rivals
Superman reminiscent of the announcer's
breathless description of the classic
superhero from the 1950s TV series
Adventures of Superman he's faster than
a speeding bullet more powerful than a
locomotive able to change the course of
Mighty rivers and Ben steel with his
bare hands yes it's super man strange
visitor from another planet who came to
Earth with powers and abilities far
beyond those of mortal men this movie
Sherlock is in other words pretty much
the Superman of the 19th century
especially Cav's strong jawed Barrel
chested version it's almost unbelievable
did they have gyms that good in
Victorian
England it's possible check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]
one